let's pick you right back up you said
you had a phase twos gravity yeah you
got to come up with your face to
strategy because okay great it's one
week run what's next for us you know the
traditional films of these studios they
have theatrical they have VOD they have
you know network they have cable they
have multi platform releases so we got
to come up with our multi-platform
release so after its head it's one we
can run we already got to be thinking
about who these folks that were going to
try to reach and invite to the screening
that we could potentially do some kind
of on demand or online deal with or
cable or network who knows you know so
we invite those people to attend you
take your meetings after and guess
whether it's another announcement so
once you do your deal that it's going to
your partnering with a company like an
indie pics or someone indie flicks or
someone like this that's a separate
announcement you work with the machine
like I said so we work together as
partners your guys going to put out a
press release make sure we have our
messaging in and then we've spread the
news that's another story and then you
send that to your network and then when
it's getting ready to come out on the
data is coming out and that's a tune
another everybody watched the film
support us it's going to come on so we
think just like the in it you know just
like the studio's do is we map out our
game plan all the way through what's
happening with it you know and then you
support it with social that's just your
misters strategy yeah I'm wondering you
know because it's so easy when you're in
this mode and you're just blasting
everybody you know it's like I'm just
going to blast out this message and then
sometimes you may just sort of bypass
protocol you know like you know maybe
you have you know I'm sure we have a ton
of email addresses where like we don't
actually have the relationship but we're
just so desperate to just get up and
send it out everybody you know should we
just go through our channels like
should we just say are you know vote
where we have pre-existing relationships
or should we take some of these like you
know maybe PR lists and different things
you know is there certain protocol like
you know are you getting yourself in hot
water but by not doing it right I think
first of all was no holds barred it's
like level off at the end of the email
you say unsubscribe so they can always
tap out if they don't want to be blasted
third I'm always updating lists and
finding new places and have a news for
the clients so I feel like you harness
your core base and then depending on
what the project is yes you build on
that list and you find other other
avenues and your partners can but i
think there's no at the end of the day
you know as long as you're not emailing
them twice a day about the movie you
know i think it's i think it's fine you
gotta you gotta tell people about your
event and your screening let's say I'm
doing it okay let's say a monthly
screening for instance I don't feel we
do enough for our monthly screening
stylish whats whys you know um a company
that does very good is DC shorts they're
very good about their branding and their
visual look um you know these guys put
out a news blast and then do a reminder
we do the same thing do it an initial
blast about the event and then we do a
reminder closer to it so everyone
everyone does it just make sure your
branding looks good make sure everything
is gorgeous and it's and it's tight and
at the end you put unsubscribe so if
they don't want to be on it they can
they can opt out but your do remember
you're delivering quality content in
different you're delivering a quality
product you know so if Coke and Pepsi
can do it why can't you
you